why hello there you excellent person you
i'm dave rubin this is the reuben report
direct message and today is october 5th
2021 do me a favor share our videos
subscribe to our channel and tap the
notification bell uh we got three
stories for you one of them is breaking
right at this very minute there is a
hearing on capitol hill with a facebook
whistleblower and i've been watching the
hearing and watching all the clips fly
on twitter and elsewhere and it's quite
interesting we're going to show you four
clips of this thing because at first she
was kind of saying yeah
you know these big tech companies and
facebook specifically are very evil and
they're manipulating us and making us
depressed and you know driving political
polarization but then suddenly she
started prescribing what the government
should do which is an odd thing to do as
a whistleblower a whistleblower you
would think would just give you the
information oh this is all the bad stuff
the secret stuff that i'm exposing but
then suddenly in the midst of the
hearing she started acting a little bit
more like an activist and actually
prescribing what congress should do and
you're not gonna believe it but it
involves censorship yeah of course of
course uh so is she a whistleblower or a
plant
we'll discuss uh part two of today's
show uh you know joe biden uh let's go
brandon that guy he uh is talking about
this debt situation and we've been
talking a lot about it how they're
pushing this idea that 3.5 trillion
dollars equals zero dollars because
they're just going to steal it from the
rich people in the corporations because
they don't pay their fair share even
though they pay pretty much everything
uh well he gave a ridiculous ramblingly
mostly incoherent little chat about what
the debt ceiling is and debt in general
and that you know we can pay back
because we just go into well you'll see
you'll see that was my version of joe
biden right there and then finally this
one i mean this is just going to be an
ongoing thing unfortunately i think
we've tr uh crossed what i would say is
a very strange and and dangerous rubicon
in america uh kirsten cinema who is the
uh senator from arizona we showed the
video yesterday of her being harassed in
the bathroom i think it was at arizona
state university if i'm not mistaken
yeah
well now she was on a plane where she
got harassed again that at an airport
after so we're going to show you some
video and we've sort of said now it's
okay to get up in their face which as
you guys know this is exactly what
maxine waters and many of the democrats
were saying all along you can get up in
their face she was talking about
republicans but now it has come home
even to her democrat people should we do
an ad first or are we going right into
story number one we're gonna do story
number one all right there you go all
right so let's talk about this facebook
whistleblower uh whistleblower situation
so this woman by the name of francis
hoggins she is actually testifying right
now as we speak you might have it even
open in another window because that's
one of the things that the internet does
you can have 800 windows open you can
pay attention to 800 things you can
actually overload your brain until
you're nothing but a drooling zombie but
i know you wouldn't do that you're
watching me you're focused you're paying
attention you're learning and you're
going to transmit this information to
other people anyway she is testifying
right now and she's a facebook
whistleblower basically
bringing some information to light on
how facebook manipulates people how it's
leading to political division how their
data mining i mean a whole bunch of
stuff that we all know
right we all know this stuff is
happening nothing that i heard her say
or that you're about to hear i think is
so mind-blowing and i would also
uh preface this all by saying that you
know we've done this before right like
we've been to this rodeo before where
congress has these hearings about big
tech usually it's a bunch of old people
who don't even know how to turn on their
computers they're asking tech people
things we never get real answers people
lie under oath as jack dorsey did to ted
cruz i mean you've seen all these things
and even the guys that i like say like
ted cruz or rand paul or whatever they
ask good questions but then nothing ever
happens after the hearing and one other
thing before i show you the video you
know i kept saying all along when trump
was president it was like there was a
chance to do something then and i was
always leery of the government getting
involved because what happens if trump
wasn't president and then suddenly the
democrats were in power and now you've
married big tech and the government even
further that seems to be the direction
we are now heading in so we've got four
videos from her and i think you'll see
why they each get more disturbing here's
number one they want you to believe in
false choices
they want you to believe that you must
choose between a facebook full of
divisive and extreme content or losing
one of the most important values our
country was founded upon
free speech
that you must choose between public
oversight of facebook's choices and your
personal privacy
that to be able to share fun photos of
your kids with old friends you must also
be inundated with anger driven virality
they want you to believe that this is
just part of the deal
i am here today to tell you that's not
true
okay so far so good right we all kind of
know this stuff there's nothing that she
said there that i think you're going oh
my god i can't believe facebook's doing
that like we know it's sort of driving
political division we know that they
manipulate the feed right the feed if it
was unmanipulated would be purely
chronological i think that's what we
mostly thought when we signed up for
these things say 20 years ago we thought
oh i follow someone or i follow an
organization
or a school or whatever it might be and
i'm just going to have a feed that's
going to be fed to me chronologically
then of course the algorithms got
involved they start looking at your
behaviors and they start feeding you
more things they could try to push you
one way politically or another way all
sorts of things so she says all that and
i don't think that's any anywhere is
mind-blowing and then of course she
mentions that this is sort of an assault
on free speech because they're giving
you false choices between things and of
course an assault on privacy so so far
uh pretty good right like she's saying
things that we believe to be true
nothing major new under the sun there
here's clip number two
could you talk more about why engagement
based ranking is dangerous and do you
think congress
should seek to pass legislation like the
filter bubble transparency act that
would give users the ability to avoid
engagement based ranking altogether
facebook is going to say
you don't want to give up engagement
based ranking you're not going to like
facebook as much if we're not picking
out the content for you
that's that's just not true there are a
lot of facebook likes to present things
as false choices like you have to choose
between having lots of spam like let's
say imagine we ordered our feeds by time
like on imessage or on
their other forms of social media that
are chronologically based
they're going to say you're going to get
spam you're going to spammed like you're
not going to enjoy your feed
the reality is that those experiences
have a lot of permutations there are
ways that we can make those experiences
where computers don't regulate what we
see
we together socially regulate what we
see
but they don't want us to have that
conversation because facebook knows that
when they pick out their the content
that we focus on using computers we
spend more time on their platform they
make more money
the dangers of engagement-based ranking
are that facebook knows
that content that elicits an extreme
reaction from you is more likely to get
a click a comment or reshare
and it's interesting because those
clicks and comments and reshares aren't
even necessarily for your benefit it's
because they know that other people will
produce more content if they get the
likes and comments and ratios they
prioritize content in your feed so you
will give little hints of dopamine to
your friends so they will create more
content and they have run experiments on
people producer side experiments where
they have confirmed this
okay so now we're getting to something
interesting here right we're getting a
little bit more of a look under the hood
as i said we all sort of thought we were
getting this unmanipulated feed years
ago but we all know it's been
manipulated and what she's saying there
is the more that you do things that
outrage people let's say the more that
that drives engagement and gets more
clicks and likes and comments and all
that the more they're going to show you
a certain type of thing and that if they
left it just to us to our own devices
well we might not be on the platform as
much our uh engagement and the amount of
time that we let that thing suck us off
for
there isn't
about that
that it would go down and obviously
that's not what they want so that's kind
of interesting and it goes to the the
tension
between oh can we just have
what i think facebook was originally
designed to be this place where you
could reconnect with old friends and
family members know a little bit about
people maybe get a little bit bit of
information versus sort of the the
monolithic
sort of all-encompassing force that it
is now part of all of our lives and i
actually want to relate a little of this
to youtube although this hearing is not
specifically about youtube but we know i
do a show on youtube right we we do
pretty well around here but we know that
youtube has
a feed and out an algorithm that feeds
you guys different things so right now
if you're watching this video you
probably have suggested videos on the
side we hope and we do everything we can
we've got our guy chris who is a great
youtube optimization guy we hope that
most of those videos are our videos so
that you'll click around through our
videos right we are in business and part
of the business is that we keep you
watching now i am not in the business of
keeping you outraged and angry and
trying to drag you
down some conspiracy hole and everything
else but youtube is sort of designed the
same way she was just describing
facebook which is the more engagement
there is on certain things the more you
might want to click it and if they see
you perhaps going in a certain political
way and they want you to go down that
way could they fill that
you